as the president of the united states
you run into a lot of
problems that comes along with being the
world's top superpower
other nations trying to take you down
groups of people threatening your
resources
bad ideas spreading from country to
country and to solve these problems one
of the options we can use is diplomacy
meeting with foreign leaders arranging
trade agreements brokering peace
agreements which is the preferred method
however sometimes diplomacy just won't
cut it
maybe the problem is with another rising
superpower that's had enough of being in
second place maybe it's a terrorist
organization that hates your country's
guts and can't be reasoned with
whatever the reason is if diplomacy
doesn't work the second
option we have is war now even though
war can be very profitable
most of the time it's just not a very
wise idea
if you declare war on another rising
superpower or a smaller country that's
in a path with said rising superpower
it could cause world war 3 or a nuclear
war which would be the end of all of us
your populace might not support going to
war at the moment which would threaten
your
power and there are a myriad of other
reasons why war might be a terrible idea
so if you have a problem that threatens
america's power and influence but
diplomacy isn't working in wars unwise
what do you do enter covert action
operations the president's third option
are tertia optio as is called behind
closed doors
covert action is basically the
president's hidden hand that allows him
to use all sorts of unconventional
warfare tactics against these national
security threats but they are done so in
a way where if your covert operations
leaked out to the public
you could just throw your hands up in
the air and say whoops i didn't know
that was happening
covert action can be a whole range of
things from drone strikes to sabotage to
paramilitary
operations snatching grabs to funding
and training rebels around the world
that oppose our enemies
with the most extreme covert operations
being assassinations
and who gets the pleasure of carrying
out these covert operations including
the assassinations
that's right the cia so let's learn how
you as the president and the cia can
protect the free world
with your third option of assassinations
theoretically of course
this video was based on the book
surprise kill vanish the secret history
of cia paramilitary armies operators and
assassins
by annie jacobson an incredible
investigative journalist great book that
covers everything you could want to know
about this subject no she didn't sponsor
this video or anything but if you do
want to dive into surprise kill vanish
you can for free thanks to our actual
sponsor audible the world's largest
audiobook platform
basically any major audiobook you want
to listen to is on there
i have been using audible almost every
day of my life for the past two years
in fact it was thanks to audible that i
came across the audiobook that forever
changed the course of my life and got me
into business the millionaire fastlane
by mj demarco
back then i wasn't into reading physical
books i was too lazy like most people
are i told myself i didn't have time and
i didn't realize that you can find
literally
every single answer to every problem in
life hidden in a book somewhere
so if it wasn't for how easy and
convenient audible makes consuming
audiobooks
you probably wouldn't be watching these
videos right now now i get to listen to
audiobooks when i eat
clean commute every single chance i get
so when they reached out for a sponsor
spot i knew i had to jump the gun on
this because this company has genuinely
changed my life for the better and i
know it can for you too
so if you pause the video right now and
go to audible.com jake tran or text jake
trend to 500 500
you'll get one audible credit which you
can use towards a free audiobook like
surprise kill vanish or millionaire
fastlane
and you'll get unlimited monthly audible
originals as well you'll also get a 30
day free trial
so if you decide to cancel you can keep
your audiobooks forever so you're
basically getting a free audio book with
no risk
so go to audible.com jaketrain or text
jake trent to 500 500 right now
the link is on the screen and in the
video description below
[Music]
[Applause]
killing a leader or prominent person at
the behest of the president
is legal under title 50 of the us code
[Music]
it's the end of world war ii the world's
greatest threat nazi germany was
defeated
europe was left in ruins which left the
us on the top
america took that pole position which
meant that they now have to do
everything in their power to stay on top
but america wasn't alone the soviet
union gained a lot of land after the war
they had a much bigger population than
the us back when sheer numbers really
did matter and they had big ambitions of
their own
and almost instantly stalin the soviet
union and communism emerged as the next
greatest threat if we falter in our
leadership
we may endanger the peace of the world
the u.s declared communism as the enemy
of democracy moscow had to be stopped
the national security act was passed in
1947 and boom
the cia was born and for the first time
in history the president had a secret
paramilitary group authorized by
congress to carry out these hidden hand
operations that we talked about in the
name of national security
at the president's beck and call this
new presidential power is what allowed
jfk to plot the kill
i mean get rid of people like castro and
it's what allowed presidents like bush
and obama to put people on a killer
capture list
and all their assassinations attempted
assassinations paramilitary operations
have all revolved around this dilemma
americas need to protect this interest
and stay on top of the world stage
without going to war
so let's say you have some kind of
leader or prominent figure that's
causing you trouble and you want to off
them
how exactly would you go about doing
that issue a standing kill order on
jason bourne effective immediately
well the first thing to understand is
that assassination is the most extreme
measure that should only be used if you
tried every other
option because things can very quickly
spiral out of control
so let's say you did try every other
option and you decide that the only way
to take care of this national security
threat is to assassinate them
well the next step is to stop calling an
assassination remember we want some
plausible deniability so if ward ever
gets out we can claim that we knew
nothing about it
president eisenhower's advisors didn't
call it assassination
no they called it eliminating
neutralizing disabling foreign leaders
with their health alteration committee
jfk referred to it as executive action
or getting rid of someone
reagan call it preemptive neutralization
george w bush called it lethal direct
action and so forth
why do they keep switching the names for
it they're burying
the information right and they keep
switching around
the they switch around who has authority
to you know say yes let's go ahead and
put this guy on the kill list i mean
that was fascinating i mean
ideally instructions for health
alterations should never be written down
or recorded
the final decision to eliminate someone
should always be reached in the field
where the elimination will happen
in a perfect world only one person will
know about your neutralization
carry out the hit and no report is made
but obviously this isn't a perfect world
so just try to keep the decision
confined to as little people as possible
once the decision is reached how you're
gonna preemptively neutralize someone is
gonna vary largely based on the
situation
shoot her before him but make sure he
sees it when this one um
kill him take him to his church dump him
in the pulpit
and i'll leave the rest up to you the
best assassination
uh i mean the best lethal direct actions
are the ones that aren't even considered
assassinations in the first place
that is the gold standard we want to
shoot for there are a few variables we
have to account for
the first one is the awareness of the
subject simple means that the subject is
unaware of the hit on him
chase is when the subject is aware that
you're after him but isn't guarded
guarded means that they know about the
potential hit and our garden
whether or not it's a simple chase or
guarded case changes how we're going to
approach it
the next variable is the desired outcome
of our assassin
lost means we want the assassin to die
with the subject safe means we want the
assassin to escape after the job is done
but whether or not it's a loss or safe
case the assassin should never fall into
the enemy's hands alive
which would be a disaster from all
angles concealment is the next variable
to consider
do you require that everyone not think
that they were assassinated that would
make this a secret case
does it matter at all if people know
that this was a hit that would make this
an open case
do you need the public to know that this
was an assassination in order for the
hit to be effective
that would make this a terrorist case in
the case of julius caesar that was a
safe
simple terroristic job meaning that the
assassin escaped caesar was unaware of
the hit on him
and they wanted the public to know about
it so now that you sorted out the
awareness of the subject the outcome of
the assassin the concealment of the case
let's move on to the assassin itself
selecting your assassin will be based on
whether or not it's a safe or lost job
whether you want the assassin to escape
afterwards or die with the subjects
for a lost case the hitman needs to be a
genuine fanatic of some sort this can be
a political religious or revenge seeking
fanatic
fanatics that are willing to neutralize
someone are probably going to be
psychologically unstable
so just handle them with care in case
they don't get neutralized themselves
you want to keep your identities a
secret if you intend for your assassin
to escape
the cia typically recruits former
special forces operators because they're
pretty much the perfect candidates
they're the best in their class this is
what they've been living and breathing
their entire lives
they retire from the military and want
to do these jobs or you can even employ
active special forces soldiers in the
case of bin laden
the misnomer is like oh the seals killed
bin laden
well they were seals trained but that
was a cia mission
because pakistan is a sovereign nation
and the military can't kill people
in countries we're not at war with so
those guys all became
essentially cia operators for the night
whoa right and if you look at
photographs as i have seen
you'll notice that they have no markings
on their
outfits so that if the job went south
it'd be like i don't know who these guys
are
overall you want them in and out as
quickly as possible you want to put a
lot of focus on the evac
after the job is done ideally you want
to give the instructions orally as we
mentioned earlier
and once you have your assassin or
assassins it's time to plan out that
pre-emptive neutralization
today the cia's most elite unit of
assassins is nicking the stalker team
made up of around 12 members all with
their own code names
the stalker team's job is to make book
on the unfortunate subjects listed on
the killer capture list stock them using
recon and surveillance tactics the caa
perfected over the years to create
dossiers on the targets
these individuals can be hiding anywhere
in caves or first world countries
once an individual is located in a
general area then it was developing
patterns what time he gets up in the
morning
what time he leaves as we mentioned
before assassinations are a last-ditch
effort that should only be finalized
when in the field and ready to strike
from there the soccer team creates plans
on how they're going to handle different
go orders they might receive
blackmail snatch and grab sabotage and
of course preemptive neutralization
how they're going to infiltrate when
where what the subject will be doing at
the time etc
so let's say you stock them come up with
a dossier plan out different go orders
and you get a go
order to give them a health alteration
how are you gonna do that
the entire point of assassination is the
absolute death of the subject now this
may sound obvious but if you don't have
a professional operator doing the job
some people might overlook the sureness
of neutralization required because of
all the emotions they're going to be
going through
the attempt on hitler's life failed
because the conspiracy did not give this
matter
proper attention a lot objects come in
handy since you'll be able to find one
where the target is and it's less likely
to scream this was a professional hit
job
if that's your concern
for secret cases where you don't want
people knowing it was a hit accidents
are your best bet
specifically assisted falling accidents
from a height of 75 feet or more
onto a hard surface now i am not
advocating this youtube gods
the cia is no that's not a joke this is
from an official document the cia
released
so falling accidents make sure it's a
hard surface there
wells elevator shafts bridges water is
too unreliable
you can case a good location set up a
meeting there act like a horrified
witness
after it happens oh there's a man
standing on the bridge what
yes he looks like look at that car
accident subway and train accidents
fires are too unreliable and of course
there's drugs
edge weapons guns other things that will
get me to monetize if i talk too much
about them
you get the idea one noteworthy
technique was employed by the kgb
let me know if you guys want a video on
them they refer to assassinations as
what matters one of their victims was a
high-profile anti-communist ukrainian
politician named lev robettes
if it wasn't for a kgb double agent that
defected to the us
we would have always thought that lev
died from a heart attack but instead as
lev was walking through a stairwell the
kgb agent passed by and used a custom
tiny poison gun
that sprayed atomized hydrogen cyanide
into left's face which caused him to
collapse and be neutralized
so now you know the origin of these
covert action operations
we needed another option when diplomacy
wasn't working and we don't want to
spark world war
iii you know how we need plausible
deniability in case of whatever gets out
via vague code names
riddles compartmentalization you know
the classifications of different
offering scenarios the awareness of the
subject the outcome of the assassin the
concealment of the case
you know what to look for in an assassin
you know how to stock and make buck on a
subject and come up with different plans
for different go orders you might
receive
and you know the different techniques
that can be used for said health
alterations
so now it's time to get out there and
get started on those wet matters
theoretically of course today the cia
soccer team is still very much active
they're still roaming the globe chasing
down and stalking foreign nationals that
have been involved in planning or
orchestrating terrorist attacks on the
u.s
the hit list is classified of course
with only one known target
the identity and fate of the rest of the
targets your guess is as good as mine
so the question remains is this third
option worth it
the alternative is doing nothing or
sending kids out to war
let me know what you think in the
beautiful place that is the comment
section below
do i think it's a good thing after
talking to a lot of
20 year old soldiers who come back from
the war theater
missing a limb or with intense ptsd and
who
essentially serve as cannon faulter i
would say
my opinion that's the second option war
the 42 guys that i interviewed they're
like send me
they are professional they are tier one
operators their green berets their seals
their delta
they retire they join the cia so they're
like
professionals at what they do and
they're saying i want someone has to do
this job
we've been doing this since the end of
world war ii i want to do
it so do i think it's better
i mean i think that
that concept speaks
to choice
right because i'm not so sure that the
20 year olds know what they're in for
and the 40 year olds know what they're
in for and are willing to do it
so that well also the difference between
now if i'm ever neutralized as you guys
like to remind me in like every single
video
you guys my tran mafia family yakuza
cult members can figure out what
happened
if you guys are new to this channel and
you enjoyed this video essay you will
probably enjoy the future ones because
we have them coming out every single
week
on business power money
what was the other one
[Music]
crime business power money and crime
if you want more of those subscribe and
turn on the notification bell
instagram if you want like behind the
scenes stuff day in the life kind of
stuff
me complaining about stuff and you want
to help me not be a pleb anymore because
i'm only
like 5 000 followers on instagram right
now
and you want to help me get the 10k so
i'm not a pleb and so i can like
aggressively
enthusiastically tell you guys to like
swipe up right now you can follow me on
instagram at jaketrend.io
that's gonna wrap it up for this video
thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake as
always stay dangerous out there guys
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
see